desoladas pero aliviadas así se
encuentran las casi trescientas niñas
que fueron liberadas después de que el
viernes hombres armados irrumpieran en
su escuela y la secuestraran en un
pueblo del nordeste de nigeria después
de reunirse con las niñas el gobernador
local dijo que fueron liberadas tras
negociaciones final son 279 niñas todas
ellas están aquí están a salvo vamos a
llevarlas a un centro médico para que
determinen su estado de salud está mal
este suceso es el último de una serie de
secuestros al que los estudiantes del
nordeste y del centro del país están
haciendo frente más de 600 han sido
secuestrados en distintos incidentes
desde diciembre el gobierno aseguró que
los grupos de hombres armados toman como
rehenes a los niños y buscan dinero a
cambio de su liberación las autoridades
negaron haber pagado rescate alguno pero
los expertos dicen que eso es improbable
las escuelas internas son muy comunes en
la región del nordeste de nigeria y
normalmente se encuentran en zonas
rurales en las que no hay seguridad o
tienes honda polis investigation todo
este asunto está bajo investigación
policial después de la investigación
podremos indicar los detalles de cómo
cuando pasó el procedimiento y las
circunstancias que se emplearon para
entrar y salir de la escuela en entender
es kurt angle nature's el viernes 27
niños fueron liberados tras ser
secuestrados en una escuela en el estado
de níger hace dos semanas en diciembre
el secuestro y la puesta en libertad de
más de 300 niños en un instituto de khan
cara provocó indignación generalizada y
trajo recuerdos del secuestro de las
niñas de chivo un rapto en el que
terroristas yihadistas tomaron como
rehenes a 276 niñas en 2014